(upbeat music)
One of the moments that I was starstruck,
I was at some event or a party,
and I looked over and saw Morgan Freeman.
And I'm just such a huge fan of his.
And I actually went up to him and said,
"Please be nice to me. I'm such a fan.
This would really, really bummed me out
if it went any other way."
And he was so kind.
'Cause not everybody's nice. I have to say that.
He's really nice
A time that I was starstruck,
a very funny story.
I'm hanging out with Will and family,
and we are on this little boat, we're in Miami,
and we get to, you know, another boat,
and I realize, "Oh, we're going to that boat."
I turn around
and I'm handing Willow off to someone, right?
So I'm taking Willow off the boat and I'm giving Willow,
she was young at the time, right?
And I turn around and it's Tom cruise.
And I've got the total dumb look on my face like,
"Oh, snap!"
So it was Tom cruise in the middle of Miami Harbor.
A moment I was starstruck was at, oh gosh,
it was actually my first time meeting Whitney Houston.
And I'll never forget meeting her in the lobby of,
at the time it was called Hotel Miko,
and we walk over,
and she is just beaming this just beautiful beam of light.
And she says hello.
And it's literally like the rest of the planet just said,
"Ooo, this is a test of the Emergency Broadcast System."
And I couldn't hear anything else.
I was just so, I mean, she's my hero,
and she's the woman that inspired me to sing.
So I tried to, I remember, come back to my body
'cause I felt like it was an out-of-body experience,
out-of-body experience.
And I sat there and listened to everything that she said,
but I still like, in my body was crying
and just freaking out.
And I will never forget that moment.
I will never forget how kind she was
and how she would just check on myself and the girls.
And I love her.
God rest her soul. I love her.
One time I was at the Globes and I remember
me and Sofia Vergara were hanging out backstage,
and we both saw Meryl Streep just chilling.
And it was just the three of us
backstage in this changing room.
And I remember Sofia and I were both like,
pushing each other in front of Meryl Streep and being like,
"Okay, who's gonna go speak to her,"
when finally she did because she's braver, clearly.
But yeah, I was a little bit starstruck.
(upbeat music)